oK you've got your centerr I now want
you to pick any two points on the
circumference so I'm going to pick this
spot over here and this spot over here
so pick a couple of spots on the
circumference of your circle okay once
you've done that I'm going to use a
fancy word here I want you to use this
arc along the bottom let's give it a
name of court P Q I want you to use R P
Q 2 September just a fancy word for make
or form I want you to use art P Q to
subdue and angle at the center and also
an angle at the circumference okay so
for instance and you can only concern
one angle at the center okay because the
center is only in one spot so there you
go I just subtract you okay it's been
subdued by arc PQ there it is there's
only one I have a few choices though
actually have an infinite number of
choices but the angles I can form some
fancy you can put them anywhere you like
I put my one somewhere like over yeah
that'll do
like so you can see it's kind of kind of
leaning over a little bit okay now you
don't have protractors they're mostly
projectors for measuring angles yet but
what I want you to notice and you can
sort of see it by eye you can confirm
when you if you do actually have a
projector I wish you have a look at this
angle that we submitted at the center
compared to the angle subtended at the
circumference does anyone know what the
relationships between these are yeah so
let's call this one R okay so the angle
Center and this is in fact the way that
we will state it the angle at the centre
is the do you said double right double
you could say twice but double is fine
as well is double the angle the
circumference and even though I think
that's sort of enough to unambiguously
within this context to describe what
you're talking about I think it's a
little more descriptive to add one more
phrase at the end which is standing on
the same arc because that's how we
constructed these remember
so what we're suggesting is this angle
twice the size of this one Eric
yep yeah yeah that's a that is a great
question if for example I'll just draw
one over here that's not the center
that's the same time so say something
like this for instance like that yeah so
one of wonderful things about this and
the reason why I've stated in this way
is that this is still true it's still
true it the proof that we'll use end up
being slightly different because as you
can see these do look like different
configurations don't they but we can
still do it just as well as we can do it
over here
okay so again I'm going to try and walk
you through I'll let you have a one
minute head start this time because this
time I just sort of gave it to you
maybe two minutes I'm generous if what
I'm trying to prove is that this angle
is double this angle and I've already
suggested to you that within circles
constructions are often very very
helpful what could you do to get towards
something like this just draw something
nothing is wrong but obviously when you
start to put too many drawing on there
it just gets clouded if you think you've
got something called me over I don't a
spoiler for everyone so have a shot all
right it's perfectly fine if you're not
done yet
the point of this is not necessarily to
get the answer but to stretch your
muscles and think geometrically it's
quite different to doing say calculus
right okay I'm just going to shuffle
this o-over a little bit because um I'm
going to make a construction now like I
said there's a few different ways to do
this there's lots and lots of ways to do
this err just show everyone that I'm
going to come to in a second I'm going
to show you my preferred proof because I
think it's it's quite nice and quick
it's only my minor difference okay so I
made a construction are oh but I didn't
construct the radius I actually went a
little bit further you don't have to go
much further you don't even have to go
to the opposite side of the circle you
just have to go past the center here's
what I'm going to do having done that
you've got maybe you see it right you've
got the same situation here as you do
over here in that you've got all these
isosceles triangles magically appearing
are you getting a hint yet in circles
you get lots of isosceles triangles
because you have radii everywhere right
they're very easy to find so for that
reason just like over there if I have a
look at say this angle at the top it's
going to be equal to have eyes
names on here I do can you tell me the
name of the angle is equal to ah
RP oh right because here are the radii
and so equal angles are opposite equal
sides yep by the same logic I can look
at this thinning triangle over here and
if this is better then this guy down
here is also better okay now you have a
couple of choices from here I know where
Eric went is that he went to these
angles inside the triangles which is
classically fine you can find out what
they are English on the triangle but
there's an even more direct way to get
to this angle that I'm interested in
right by the way I've called this angle
alpha in this angle beta so in theory
what should this angle be equal to if my
property is right what should it be
equal to it should be equal to exactly
double alpha plus beta which is 2 alpha
plus 2 B you agree watch angles they're
related to this one what's the
relationship between alpha and alpha and
this guy right here this one in here
this one in here I'll give you a clue
it's outside the triangle we have a word
for outside a fancy technical just means
outside exterior right the exterior
angle the triangle is equal to what Big
C the exterior angle triangle is equal
to the sum of the opposite two interior
angles do you see that because really
what you're doing is what you're saying
but twice this is 180 minus these guys
but this is 180 minus that because it's
on the other side of straight line so
you can just go directly there this guy
is going to be 2 alpha because the
exterior angle of a triangle this is
your reason equals the sum of the
opposite two interior angles okay and by
the way I don't remember that wording I
remember the picture and then the words
just kind of come from there okay I
don't remember this wording either I
just look at the shape same logic what's
this guy and he asked nestled in here
it's going to bethe
and literally for exactly the same
reason and you're done
that's 2 alpha plus 2 beta double the
angle at the circumference as required
okay